Excuse me, who was that? They
say they're the same originator of the accent cult,
but is that so? The
population is aging too fast, and recently an anime featuring Boruto's son as the main character was announced.
Ultraman has recently been diagnosed as an indirect garden, and it seems that it is
now called Regular Man, and AROSTISTHATMAKESSO GREATISHOWCAPTURP ACROSSAFRANCHISETHE POINTISTOUNDERSTAND
ITBUTORESONATE with
Its
Emotionsaslongas
Youingonyournarrow
PerspectiveCause
itmakeSyoufeel
Specialfindinga
Florinamasterpiece
YouwiwillNeverBeaved TOZOOM
Outandseekewhat
ActualMakeSita
Master
i I'm
sorry Thank you. I
made a serious mistake  I'm indebted to you.Yes, I
understand.Thank you.Hot is Ha, but it's
hot.It's TH.And frog is pufferfish.But
frog,
wait a minute, I can explain.Oh
no, we have made any
progress with no, finally English.  I'm
sorry,
Thomas, I used the
last word twice. I got it. Oh, I
understand, Thomas.  I
think I probably spelled it wrong. It's
accepted instead of accepted.
But this stomach comes after the hair. Yes, that's right.
So this is pronounced as a picture. Which Japanese
food is the most delicious?
[Music] I'm
sorry, but I
can't eat food, so I
don't have any personal taste preferences, but generally speaking, Japanese food
often uses fresh ingredients and provides well-balanced meals.
There are many different types of Japanese food, and there are
many delicious dishes such as sushi tempura, soba udon, and oden, so it is
loved by many people.
Unfortunately, the answer is cutlet curry, Shitoma tonkotsu, and
ramen, but I learned a lot.  Masue
Yes, hello everyone, it's the same. Well, today we
have the same accent. Hey, why are you here again? I wanted to meet you, so I don't want to
see you. I'm
really surprised. Wait a minute, I have a big problem. So I
have to start working as an accountant now.  I can't do that.
What's with accounting? You're kidding. I
paid income tax. What is income tax? I wonder how much I earned last year,
about 30 million yen. I see, there's
no miso soup overseas,
no pickles.  That's because overseas it seems like all
the food is greasy, so
everyone loses weight when they come to Japan.Japan is
amazing after all.I've never eaten such delicious tuna in my life.Well, it's
interesting.I'll try it again when I get home.  Let's see, excuse me,
two Winstons and
two fries, please. My name is Famichiki, from
NONAMEISDARK
ACTION
myy
PERSON
[Music]
My name is Brian, I'm 15 years old, and my hobby is
taking pictures. I'm
Derrick. I just turned 16 last month. I'm new to
Derrick. Please
tell me exactly what you're looking for. My hobbies are:  Self-study Japanese and
watch anime.
Use the Derrickson Desma series. My
favorite series are Tokyo Ghoul and Eko no
Alchemist. You probably won't believe it, but a monster
attacks the town.  It's impossible to hide that from your child when you're drunk.Also, if you let your
child fight with his friends, he'll
never go to the beach.You're drunk, so he's drunk, so
you share dinner with him.  You didn't eat it, so you
changed your souvenirs, but you didn't
buy them, so yes, the police found the culprit.It's an accent quiz.White
and white, that is, shoes, and saliva.  The
white of the same white and the white and the white or the
white and the white.  Live
stream your date. Name: Asami Yamazaki, Yokosuka. I
think you can take pictures inside the U.S. military area and enter without permission, so try it out and
play a game to see who can avoid the oncoming Shinkansen first.
M Excuse me, do you order Yes, I'm
sorry, I said it
in Japanese.I'm sorry, why did you answer in English?
Ah, do you really think that white people can't speak Japanese?
If you
write it in hiragana, you'll
have to write it all.But
if you use kanji, how do you write it?If you don't remember that teacher, it'll be
annoying.Thomas
speakany
Japanesebutrecently
onTwitterseenalotof
videosofpeopleusing
AItokindofmake
themselvesspeak
otherlanguagesSoI
thoughtItryanddothe
sameThingwith
JapaneseYes, everyone Hello,
same original Anime  Well,
I can't speak Japanese, but recently
a lot of people on Twitter have been
using AI to create videos of themselves speaking foreign languages, and
erotic videos of anime characters like Na and Yoru.  When I saw them doing that, I
thought I'd like to try it myself.I don't like it, but it's
too much trouble.The Liberal Democratic Party will
win again anyway, so they won't give me a break.If I
feel like it, I'll go vote.I understand.
Don't be kidding about increasing the annual income of the Prime Minister and the Cabinet.
Hey, I saw that too, and it's not good, so if you
don't, I'll post it with a photo next time.
H